Iran is unique in the world today it has
tens of thousands of victims of chemical
weapons use during the iran-iraq war in
the 1980s sulfur mustard nerve agents
for the first time were used on the
battlefield in that war it's been more
than thirty years since these victims
were exposed to the chemicals and now
scientists are unraveling the long-term
effects and also looking at the basic
mechanisms of chemical weapons and how
they affect the body initially the acute
effects and then in the long term as
these consequences happened many years
later I am Richard stone international
news editor for science I went to Iran
to report on survivors of chemical
weapons attacks and a project sponsored
by the ulcer Center or crisis reporting
the first large-scale use of chemical
weapons was during World War one that
was mostly mustard and chlorine there
was many years after that that chemical
weapons were used on a large scale in
the battlefield and that took place
during the iran-iraq war sulfur mustard
is very corrosive chemical it's not like
the nerve ages it's been around for more
than a century it was used in World War
one but its mechanism of action is still
rather opaque it blisters so if you get
on the skin it forms this huge blisters
called Lula if you breathe it in it
attacks the lung cells and if you get
into your eyes it can also cause quite
quite big damage there as a oily
substance it is absorbed quite easily
so if you survive sulfur mustard it
takes a while for you to heal the
blister is take months to heal many
years later people are discovering that
the lung damage that was a caused by the
acute exposure
it sets a molecular mechanism in motion
like a little time bomb that explodes
later into very life-threatening
symptoms that the lung tissue breaking
down you become more prone to lung
infections and a lot of people succumb
months or years later after the exposure
to these effects and the mechanism
molecular mechanism of these effects is
still being worked out so Iran has a
huge population of mustard victims who
are still suffering symptoms tens of
thousands of people it's a unique cohort
to try to develop better strategies to
treat mustard and also if there's some
way to develop chemicals compounds that
can be applied during the initial attack
right now that antidote to sulfur
mustard does not exist
all nerve agents attack an enzyme called
acetylcholinesterase it's vital to the
body it breaks down the neurotransmitter
acetylcholine so it is essential for
maintaining levels of the
neurotransmitter in the synapses one of
the most insidious effects and nerve
agents is that after they bind to sotl
choline esterase this bond over time
hardens becomes permanent essentially
and this is called aging so as acetyl
choline builds up in the synapses it
over stimulates the nerves nerve cells
and that has a variety of effects so it
can lead to seizures convulsions when
the nerve agent enters the brain and
starts interacting with the enzyme there
it sends victims into a coma and unless
they're treated really quickly they will
usually stop breathing so soldiers who
are exposed to nerve agents carry three
countermeasures that they can self
inject or inject into a buddy one is
called atropine it binds to the same
enzyme that the nerve agents bind you
there for preventing the nerve agent
from exerting its effects another is an
oxime that if nerve agent is attached to
the enzyme it prise it off so it's like
a little molecular crowbar and the third
is an anticonvulsant one of the major
symptoms of nerve agent exposure is
seizures and this anticonvulsant takes
care of that's it
for a long time people thought that if
you're supposed to nerve agent either
lived or died if you survived the nerve
agent attack you wouldn't on to live a
normal average healthy life it didn't
have long-term effects people assumed
that began to change especially after
the Tokyo terror attacks
it was clearly documented that people
exposed to sarin did suffer long-term
consequences that's a new revelation and
Iranian scientists see an opportunity
now to try to track down victims of the
nerve agent attacks and monitor their
current health and see if they can
contribute to the development of the
long-term effects of nerve agents so
this is a unique resource for scientists
it's a very tragic story for the victims
but to be able to study using modern
tools the effects of chemical weapons on
the human body this is the only place
right now where scientists can do that
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]